here everyone had a part to play
cinderella really wouldn't be the same
without its gorgeous wardrobe the camila
cabello led cinderella retelling is all
about fashion from the aspirations of
the titular princess the stylish looks
of billy porter's magical fab g and of
course all the glamorous ballroom
dresses costume designer ellen mirage
nick definitely did not disappoint with
her fabulous work for the jukebox
musical this is gorgeous yes future
queen yeah this cinderella makes plenty
of changes to the timeless story and one
of the most notable is the fact that
billy porter plays a now genderless
fairy godmother somebody as fashionable
as porter couldn't just have any old
outfit so costume designer ellen
miragnik cooked up something special for
the pose star porter's primary costume
consists of a gilded gown complete with
reflective shades that were inspired by
the wings of a butterfly porter stressed
that it was vital that the costume
represents both masculine and feminine
elements nothing in life ever stays the
same
good
or bad perhaps the biggest challenge for
costume designer ellen miragnik was
designing cinderella's iconic ball gown
i realized that this was the biggest
challenge of the entire show cinderella
being the designer and i was the ghost
designer mirage nick decided not to go
with the blue hues that became so iconic
in the disney versions and also wanted
to avoid any tinges of red it was very
much guided by lightness air and
glittering light the end result was a
dress that not only felt appropriate for
the tone of the film but helped it stand
on its own from the other countless
adaptations of the classic tale it's a
cinderella for the 21st century
cinderella's silhouette design for the
film was actually inspired by the glass
slipper as camila cabello had to
practice her draping skills it actually
helped inspire the flower petal like
layers of the skirting the whole entire
gown curves continually whether it be
the folds on the skirt or in the
waterfall on the back on the back is
this massive bouquet of flowers that is
just beautiful
anyway you can make them more
comfortable billy porter had quite a bit
of creative insight when it came to fab
g's accessories porter had insight in
the inclusions of his character's
glittery wand and custom jimmy choo
boots porter had also helped with
designing the magical character's
horse-drawn carriage that looked more
like a sports car than the typical
pumpkin carriage from the classic tail
that's certainly one way to modernize
cinderella
the cinderellas have always featured the
main character working away in ratty
clothes for her cruel stepmother and
stepsisters while her character may not
have been a fan of the clothes camila
caveo felt differently i loved my work
costumes they were so comfortable but
still had ella's swag to them the team
behind this new incarnation wanted to
give an update to the outfit not by
making it modern but more relatable and
workable
cinderella's work clothes and tales of a
simple white cotton long sleeve slip
that is layered underneath a corset
topped dress that is hiked up at the
ankles
the most modern part of this costume is
the triple wrapped brown leather belt
bag that was the modern touch because i
just thought it actually suited her and
when she went to town quietly to try to
make transactions
the design of tallulah greaves princess
gwen's borderline futuristic and
streamlined silhouettes with sharp power
shoulders even black brocade and
metallic embroidered palette are
described by ellen miragnik as a bit
classic a bit serious the costume
designer aimed to completely avoid any
cues associated with a particular time
period her shoulders were strong her
fabrics were sturdy the shapes were very
clean and not floaty at all to indicate
her seriousness about where her
intentions lie as the people's princess
and what she wanted to do with herself
the place the town the city
while the hair stylists on set of
cinderella used plenty of different hair
products while filming one in particular
was used on every cast member frizz e's
john frieda moisture barrier firm hold
hairspray quite the lengthy name sharon
martin and her team swore up and down by
the hairspray the days are long and we
need to keep everyone looking fresh that
really helped keep the hair looking soft
and done without being too set
cinderella's wicked stepsisters drizella
and anastasia required a more flamboyant
and showy design for their wardrobe from
flashy colors and their
over-embellishments on top of a blending
of a more modern influence with period
silhouettes mirage nick designed the
dresses so that they would have the two
characters wardrobes match their
personalities they too were very
presentable there is no marriage market
in cinderella but there is the hope that
a suitor would come calling and one of
the sisters would become engaged or
married so they were always somewhat
dressed to the nines
unlike many of the other characters
wardrobes idina menzel's vivian's
clothes actually do hearken back to a
particular decade just not one you'd
expect the 80s her jewel tones her vivid
prints and [ __ ] blouses are all visibly
representative of the era in fact much
of menzel's wardrobe was based off of
the 80s era of legendary designer
christian lacroix the ball gown worn by
menzel was all hand embroidered in order
to create all the ball gowns that were
to represent cultures from all around
the world the costume department brought
around 200 quinceanera dresses directly
from mexico and fitted them up so they
were ready even before filming was shut
down due to the pandemic we had a full
team great assistants cutters and
stitchers the dresses had to be taken
apart and everything else was
refashioned redesigned and refabricated
to become this overly done ball
the team behind cinderella were adamant
about making the film centered around
female empowerment and that meant not
putting any woman down including
cinderella's stepsisters who are
typically described as ugly makeup head
sharon martin was careful while
designing the characters of anastasia
and drizella anastasia was made up to
have a look of innocence like someone
who is not driven by fashion and glam
drizella on the other hand was all on
board with the glamour of hair makeup
fashion and finding a husband i think of
her as a kardashian she was always fully
made up you couldn't tell if she had
just woken up or if she's going to a
ball i'ma go see if he needs a wife nope
both sharon martin and billy porter
agree that they didn't want porter's fab
g look to come across as drag queen as
they wanted to normalize a man in makeup
as well as mainly billy porter's classic
look on his eyes he wore cat eyeliner
and feather-like faux lashes to complete
his look and give fab g that magical
feeling i
am your fabulous god mother
sharon martin didn't want to adhere to
stereotypes of female characters in
movies similar to cinderella and instead
wanted to truly expand upon what the
women would look like in this modern
reinvention of cinderella martin wanted
to make sure that the women in the film
looked fierce and strong i wanted bold
looks for them not just the nicely
blushing fainting look just because a
beautiful man speaks to them or
something like that while the
stepsisters anastasia and drizella were
always made up and always looked primed
to go to the ball that wasn't the case
for designing idina menzel's vivien
martin wanted there to be a sort of
messiness to vivien as she was always
trying to prep her daughters instead of
just herself and just hasn't gotten
herself completely ready maybe the
stepmother isn't so wicked after all you
may think me cool
ellen mirage nick made a reference to
the 2018 chanel runway for bridgerton in
the dream sequence where cinderella is
running a successful dress shop i
thought well she'd be a little chanel
girl you know so i made a little top and
a tool skirt that's very fashionable of
miss miragnik from the glamorous and
snazzy dresses to the preppy makeup and
hair the team behind cinderella's
wardrobe definitely excelled when it
came to bringing the timeless fashion to
a modern take on the classic story
what was your favorite
[Music]